hello welcome to this online symposium
of Hillsdale College thank you for
joining us report from the College
we're restricted here but thriving we
can go to Home Depot and buy shovels and
garden hose but we can't buy seeds
because that would spread the virus and
now we can go out on kayaks and canoes
but boats with motors are forbidden and
that means there's somebody in the
governor's office making lists of things
that we can do and not do and I don't
know who that person is but I bet a lot
of money that person knows nearly
nothing about the corona virus
he's a governor's office person I
mentioned so they have not forbidden
thinking and talking and that's what we
do for a living so we have lots of
conferences like this online conference
every year you're invited we have them
on the campus four times a year but
we're going to do this virtually and
until and unless they forbid thinking
and talking which would not astonish me
what are we talking about and thinking
about well the corona virus that's what
everybody's thinking about and we want
to try to understand the virus and we're
gonna look at its origins in this first
session with the person who discovered
the origins and then we're going to look
at the economic effects of the virus and
the shutdown and we're going to look at
the epidemiological studies and how
they're changing and whether or not it
was predictable that they would change
somebody in the search that it is so
we're gonna have a thorough look at all
this and try to figure out how we can
get back to freedom as soon as possible
the first guest is a member the United
States Senate he's from Arkansas as am I
the joke that we would be Cousins is not
true but we have been friends for a long
time got to be twenty years now he's a
very serious man he grew up on a farm in
Darnell Arkansas he ended up at Harvard
College and then Harvard Law School and
then he consulted for a while and he
he joined the law firm and in Washington
and he was about to start making some
enough money to support himself I know
all about this because I know his sister
is also a lawyer and does his taxes and
she said yeah just when he got to a
place where he could make some money he
up and joined the army he did that after
9/11 because we'd been attacked and he
thought he should go assail the people
who had attacked us and he did in Iraq
and then again in Afghanistan won a
Bronze Star and then he got out and he
was again in a great position to make
him make a big income but he ran for
Congress and then the next term he ran
for Senate and he was elected to both by
large majorities and I will tell you
he's a very significant man it's a big
future for us in the country and how did
you get into this Tom tell us about that
how did it start what's the story there
well it was back in early mid January
Larry that I first began to see news
coming out of mostly publicly available
if somewhat obscure news sources in East
Asia about a viral pneumonia of unknown
origins in Wuhan this was after China
had finally fessed up to the w-h-o on
December 31st but still when they were
denying that it could transmit from
humans to humans and they were saying
that they had things under control
there's no cause for alarm no reason to
declare a global health emergency or
imposed travel restrictions but I began
to look at what they were doing
internally they were shutting down
schools nationwide not just in Wuhan
they were literally welding or boarding
up doors on high-rise apartment
buildings and Wu hen they allowed the
puppet government in Hong Kong to shut
down air travel from the mainland into
Hong Kong the disconnect between their
rhetoric and their actions is what told
me that Beijing knew that this virus was
very severe and that we should start
preparing for it immediately so you may
recall back in mid to late January the
impeachment trial was going on in
Washington but on several occasions I
stepped out of the trial to make
phone calls the president other senior
administration officials to discuss the
virus and discuss steps that we should
be taking that started with the
restrictions on air travel from China
into the United States but that was what
really brought my attention first to the
matter in mid-january the contrast
between Chinese Communist rhetoric on
the one hand and their actions on the
other hand and what reaction do you get
from those first announcements so many
people as you might imagine considered
it alarmist they thought that perhaps it
was trying to distract away from the
impeachment trial I remember the first
briefing that the Senate had in late
January with all the reporters
congregated outside the room of course
almost every question coming out of that
briefing the Senators was about
impeachment not about the coronavirus
but as I said in a Armed Services
Committee hearing not on the Senate
floor which of course was locked up by
the trial that this was the biggest
story in the world and probably would be
for some time but certainly the media
didn't think so at the time the
president was concerned about the virus
from the very beginning that's why he
imposes travel restrictions thanks for
which he was decried it's racist
xenophobic hysterical which the w-h-o
condemned which China condemned which
many Democrats condemned but we now know
bought us lots of very valuable time of
course within his administration there
was a division of opinion many in the
security area recognized just how severe
the virus could be like me others were
concerned about the economic impact and
that's understandable as was the
president because he sits at the peak of
the government he has to consider all
those factors and something doctor foul
Chia said since then that he gives
public health advice but that can't be
the only advice on which an elected
president in the Congress makes
decisions but ultimately the president
despite that division of opinion move
forward the travel restrictions and then
as time went on I think more and more of
the senior administration officials just
like senators and congressmen just like
the American people began to realize the
severity of the virus and the risk
probably outweighed the short-term
economic impact of things like the
travel restrictions on China or
travelers
Shinzon europe some of those concerns
now in retrospect seem quaint given the
catastrophic economic toll this virus
has taken on our economy as a whole and
really the global economy as a whole
well the always reliable New York Times
has written of you in this context that
you are one of the most irresponsible
and dangerous people in federal office
and the Washington Post in that great
it's like getting a medal from the
military which you've had Washington
Post Tom cotton keeps repeating a
coronavirus conspiracy theory that was
already debunked in that funny yeah so
that goes back a couple months in late
February really in order January I first
started pointing out that we knew from
really mid January that the so-called
wet market the food market in Wuhan
where you can buy live or recently
slaughtered animals including many
exotic animals was not the source of
this virus that is a Chinese cover story
how do we know that one the best
evidence we have is that the kind of
bats or other animals from which this
virus is believed to have jumped to
humans weren't even present in the
market to a study of Chinese scientists
not Western scientists but Chinese
scientists who are under the thumb of
the Chinese Communist Party nevertheless
was released in January in The Lancet
respected medical journal that said of
the first 40 cases 14 had no contact at
all with the food market including the
very first case that they could identify
as one of them put it that virus went
into the market before it came out of
the market so therefore I simply started
raising the point that there are two
viral adji labs in the vicinity of that
food market once just a few hundred
yards away one's a couple or about eight
miles away and we know they research
coronaviruses we know they have bats
present we now know that US diplomats in
China were very worried about their
safety levels and that surely it was
only the responsible thing to do given
the fact that China had lied about the
food market being the original site of
the outbreak to ask the question and
demand China's answers of course they
give me those answers they're still
intimidating anyone who tries to
cooperate with the probe of that matter
they're just destroying evidence as they
have from the very beginning so I now
believe as I wrote in The Wall Street
Journal last week that the most
plausible explanation is there was an
accidental breach of research conducted
in one of those laboratories and that
accidental breach unleashed this
pandemic on the world we may never know
for sure there's no director conclusive
evidence intelligence rarely works in
that way but all of the circumstantial
evidence at this point leads in one
direction and that's to one of those two
labs in Lu Han now the head of the World
Health Organization has congratulated
China repeatedly on its transparency
what about that well the head of the
World Health Organization is a Chinese
Communist apologist dr. Ted Rose was a
minister and Ethiopia's government years
ago when a theo pia became one of the
first clients of china's belton road
initiative which quickly brings with it
corruption bribes kickbacks and so forth
China aggressively campaigned for him in
2017 to become the head of the w-h-o and
from the very beginning in January dr.
Ted Rose has been apologizing for China
he's been spinning China's cooperation
which is really a lack of cooperation
he's been cascading national leaders
like President Trump or European leaders
for imposing any kind of travel
restrictions on China at the outset of
this or pointing out that the most
plausible explanation for this virus's
origins is in one of those labs and just
recently when China increased the number
of reported deaths in Wuhan even though
it's still vastly under reporting them
of course the w-h-o is not there with
organized talking points and spinning in
favor of Chinese transparency and
responsibility and all of the great
wonders of the Chinese Communist Party
that's why there's really no way that we
can trust what dr. Chad drew says
especially when it comes to order
ultimately political questions about the
Chinese government not scientific
questioned about this virus I take it
you support president Trump defunding
the world
Health Organisation very much so until
we can have responsible and accountable
leadership there that is not an
apologist for the Chinese Communist
Party which remember pays a fraction of
what the United States pays you can
reasonably ask why they are so
sympathetic to Chinese interests so it's
time for the w-h-o but to have a
accounting of what they did in the early
days of this iris and continue to do and
also commit to more accountable
transparent reforms in the future if not
in the United States needs to take the
lead with other leading democracies
around the world and establishing an
organization that will actually be
dedicated to world health not world
politics but we get a lot of the stuff
we need for this pandemic and similar
things from China what about that yeah
that's a terrible mistake that our
leaders have made over the last thirty
years we're beginning to see that so
much of the stuff that we need to make
the physical things not letters and
words that move around on computers and
wires but the stuff that we need like
face masks and gloves and gowns and
drugs have to be made at least in part
if not at whole in the United States
just like we treat our defense
industrial base we ought to have treated
things like our pharmaceutical industry
or personal protective equipment and so
forth so it's a simple fact that China
supplies much of these goods not just
the United States but to the rest of the
developed world and they are currently
using that fact as leverage against the
United States and lots of our partners
and allies around the world that's why
it's urgent that we reverse those
decisions in the last 30 years I know
some people say you can't decouple our
economy from China it's irreversible it
can't be done at a reasonable price I
say that's false this is the result of
deliberate policy decisions in
Washington over the last thirty years it
can be the result of different
deliberate policy decisions in the
coming months and the years ahead and
the fact is although we get the
predominant share of such equipment from
China it's not exclusive to China nor is
it exclusive to developing countries
either much of our pharmaceuticals for
instance
come from advanced industrial
democracies like Japan Italy Austria
Denmark if they're producing it right
now there's no reason that we can't
produce it in the United States as well
at a reasonable cost and I think most
Americans having seen the results of
this pandemic or saying that they'd be
able willing to pay a little bit more
for things like their drugs or face
masks or other medical devices and
supplies if it means that no country can
ever threaten our safety and well-being
in the future oh yeah I'm the free
trader myself Winston Churchill was but
I'm aware that Abraham Lincoln was not
and that means it doesn't seem to me
like a precept of the natural law I once
talked with one of the greatest
economists of the 20th century I won't
say his name because I admire him so
much but he said it would be better even
if somebody's engaged in predatory
dumping economically from the point of
view of the whole world and us to let
them keep doing it
and I replied okay what if they got
better at making and cheaper at making
nuclear submarines than he did should we
let make those and he replied good point
yeah that's it that's exactly right leer
it's one thing for China to make you
know cheap plastic toys or lawn chairs
it's another thing for them to make
dozens of the advanced pharmaceutical
ingredients that end up in our finished
drugs in the United States or to have
the global market cornered on things as
basic as ibuprofen or acetaminophen
penicillin or antibiotics we have always
known that we have to maintain our
defenses industrial base I think
increasingly nail the ice in Washington
are finally open to the fact that we
have to do that in our pharmaceutical
and our manacle manufacturing base as
well as other critical industries as
well like telecommunications information
technology computer science and so forth
and unfortunately that's not just a
matter for China either although that's
the most serious and gravest country
because they're an enemy and they have
the market cornered in so many of those
goods but in a pandemic we've seen over
the last three months as we've seen
throughout history there really are not
many allies and partners who you can
to send the equipment and the drugs that
you need in a moment of need if they
have equal need that's why it's so
important that at least some if not all
this manufacturing capacity be based in
the United States not even in allied
countries you say they're using leverage
can you talk about in what way they do
that sure so in January when they were
still lying about the severity of this
virus they were actually buying up a lot
of personal protective equipment not
only were they making it but they were
also buying it from other countries that
do too not only for their own people but
ultimately to hoard as well they've now
been demanding that countries who
receive these goods
you know issued laudatory statements or
favorable social media pose that senior
leaders if not the senior leader prime
ministers of country greet the
deliveries at the airports when they're
coming in notwithstanding the fact that
a lot of this equipment is turning out
to be defective or shoddy they're
delaying the export of a lot of American
owned products and American China things
they're owned by countries like 3m more
smaller pharmaceutical companies that we
know live up to American standards
because they're American owned on the
grounds that they need to have quality
control well that's not really a concern
of the Chinese government in most cases
what they're doing there that is to try
to get leverage over the United States
government to not investigate the
origins of this virus to not call out
Chinese lies and misbehavior they're
doing it all around the world and
they're going to continue to do it as
long as we give them that kind of
leverage against us I know long if we
moved to Hillsdale I took my wife and
family over to Chicago so they could see
traffic which they were missing and we
went to the Field Museum and there was
an a display of the of Chinese treasures
from the great dynasties and in the
biggest room there was a big poster and
it Sanks the Chinese government for
their humanitarianism in making these
treasures available to the world and it
was sort of sick of Fame
entik but it was sitting it was it was
on the wall right next to a mural of the
emperor coming into a village and
everyone in the village had his forehead
on the ground in this mural and I
thought I wrote a letter to the director
and he didn't write back and I said you
know did you ever contrast that
statement with that mural isn't that way
in that alley live you know if the
government say I mean the welded people
into their rooms for goodness sakes and
you know that'll keep them getting out I
guess yeah and there what do you what do
you think of larger Chinese ambitions
what are they up to
well they want to achieve global
preeminence over the United States they
want to use that preeminence economic
diplomatic political financial military
to rewrite the international rules in
their favor you know to take away an
emphasis on democracy on respect for the
rights of man on playing by the rules
that we've established in the
international order since 1945 they do
that in a lot of different ways they do
it through their belt and Road
initiative and the money and the
corruption that brings along with it
they bring it through ranked
intimidation especially on their own
country's borders through disinformation
and propaganda campaigns as it was
recently reported they've engaged young
related to the virus so there's no end
to the ways that China is attempting to
replace the United States as the
globally preeminent power they obviously
don't want a military conflict with the
United States because they know they
would lose at least they would lose for
the time being but they have a
deliberate long-standing plan that's
only been accelerated under Xi Jinping
and that he is actually trying to use
this pandemic to accelerate even faster
but it is well well coordinated
considered takes the long view and looks
in the decades ahead to replace the
United States as the dominant power in
the world that therefore gets to call
the shots in the way the world is run a
couple of years ago there was a
a meeting of the Chinese Communist Party
and she gave a four-hour speech in which
he proclaimed himself whatever he is for
life and the New York Times report
explains that there were spontaneous
eruptions of dancing and waving posters
in joy at his for our speech and I
thought when I read that that guy must
be a really good talker
sounds like the spirit of Walter durante
still reigns at the New York Times
that's something I mean that's you know
leonid brezhnev used to give four and
five hour speeches to the duma and
everybody pretended to be interested
yeah and look but look up that sick of
antic reporting got the New York Times
Larry along with the Wall Street Journal
in the Washington Post China kicked out
their reporters from mainland China just
last month probably because they didn't
want anyone snooping around and how this
virus originated or what the actual
reported numbers were in China and what
helped China was exporting the pandemic
to try to achieve its goal of global
preeminence what what should be first of
all it's good China's going to be a big
issue in the election there's still an
election this year and it's still of the
first importance how the China issue
gonna play how do you think the
president has done in regard to China
and what's what are gonna be the attacks
on him well go back to the last election
China is a central issue in that
campaign as well if you look at some of
the things that set the president apart
from what you might call more orthodox
or conventional Republicans who are
running against him his views on things
like foreign policy and trade obviously
Hillary Clinton was a badly flawed
candidate when it came to China Joe
Biden though is even more flawed and
been around Washington even longer been
one of the central proponents of the
idea that somehow if we introduced
capitalism to China it would change
China whether China as opposed to China
changing capitalism much for the worse
so Joe Biden has a long and very
poor record on China in particular and I
do think it would be a central issue in
the campaign
well before this pandemic of course
Americans had all kinds of reasons to be
hostile towards China from stealing our
jobs and our factories to stealing our
intellectual property like rice farmers
in Arkansas and no they stole the rice
genomes to persecuting Christians or
other religious minorities
locking them up in gulag re-education
camps forcing abortion on their women
harvesting organs of political prisoners
threatening our partners and allies in
the region and therefore risking
conflict with our troopers there's lots
of reasons before this pandemic for
people to have been critical of China
and to oppose American political
candidates who were sympathetic to China
but after this pandemic of course
there's even more reason to do so yeah I
used to work with a man named Stephen
Mosher who's a great China expert he's
the man who discovered the forced
abortions in a Chinese village he was
the first Western scholar to get to go
study in one and he wrote a paper and I
remember it distinctly it was about the
time that Li pong became the head guy
and he said that it's a new generation
now and what they are is Western trained
engineers and what they think they're
going to do is engineer the entire
society and that they can make it great
because they can bring scientific
principles to rule so that's not exactly
orthodox Marxist lenin ism but on the
other hand they probably learned that in
western universities and they're
probably a lot of people in America
including in high places in government
who look in thinking look at that and
think yeah that's the future yeah
unfortunately there's a lot of Chinese
students in our universities who are
here to learn about advanced science
math technology engineering and then go
back and put it to use for the Chinese
Communist Party as you say it's not
exactly Orthodox Marxism Leninism but it
is authoritarian and it's
creeping towards totalitarian when you
consider the best social controls that
Beijing exerts over its people I have to
say that's another area where we have to
take stock of our relationship with
China and a hundreds of thousands of
students who are in this country at a
minimum saying that they're not allowed
to study in those advanced scientific
and technological fields the graduate or
postgraduate level you know what they
should do is get a program like
Hillsdale offers you know we should
admit Chinese students to come here if
they want to study Aristotle and the
Bible and the Federalist Papers and
Abraham Lincoln but if they want to
study quantum computing then they can
stay in mainland China for that because
China China China needs the Federalist
Papers a lot more than they need quantum
computing there you go I can confide
that I won't say the woman's name but
there's a leader a certain leader in
Hong Kong and I have offered to scholar
scholarships to young people who might
be excluded from Chinese universities
because of their activities during the
demonstrations and I think I'm going to
get some names from her and you know
they are very interested she is very
interested and how you build a political
system that has strength and stability
and freedom and you know we are we wrote
the book about that we are the ones who
can do that although we got to keep it
still so what do we do I mean what what
what are the right range of policies to
meet the Chinese threat they have to be
a wide range right yeah they are
extremely wide-ranging because the
Chinese threat is so wide-ranging of
course in the end the the simplest
question about international politics is
if there's a war who's gonna win it and
there's no doubt that right now the
United States remains the strongest
military power in the world but there's
also no doubt that for 30 years China
has had the ambition to displace us this
is a strongest military power that's why
it's so important that we continue to
invest in and modernize our nuclear
deterrent forces
that we build out next generation
stealth fighters and bombers
next generation submarines that we
rapidly produce the kind of intermediate
range missiles that we were prohibited
by a defunct obsolete treaty from
building until President Trump withdrew
from it a few months ago all these
things we need urgently to deter Chinese
aggression against our allies and gets
our partners in the western Pacific and
ultimately to push us out of the western
Pacific and we need those things not
because we want to use them but
precisely because we never want to have
to use them we never want to be in a
position where China feels that it can
challenge us militarily but that's only
the most fundamental part of
international politics there's a whole
host of things that we should do to
advance our injurer interests and to
stop China from trying to establish
itself as the preeminent power so for
instance bringing back a lot of that
manufacturing capacity to the United
States or at least trading with our
partners not our enemies we never did
that Soviet Union the Cold War we
shouldn't be doing it with China now
that export driven manufacturing economy
is what has powered China's rise so
simply taking that away from China would
be a grievous blow to them there's a lot
of other steps we can take as well for
instance allowing American courts
despite traditional doctrines of
sovereign immunity to hear cases against
Chinese leaders for unleashing this
pandemic on the world and posing
sanctions on Chinese leaders who we know
lied about this pandemic and
dramatically dramatically increased its
severity canceling all those visas for
Chinese Communist Party offspring who
are sitting around our most advanced
laboratories learning about some of the
world's most sophisticated and advanced
science as well countering Chinese
disinformation even in Hollywood where
you may have noticed there's hardly ever
a bad guy coming from China or in our
major newspapers for the Chinese
Communist Party repeatedly runs glossy
inserts that are designed to look like
news but early Chinese communist
propaganda these are just a few steps
that we can take there's a lot more but
it has to be focused and deliberate and
has to be well planned four years ahead
to ensure that you
States remains what we have been for so
long the preeminent global power and a
model for the way other countries can be
governed and can live in freedom with
prosperity and safety hmm I have learned
something of late that leads to a
general suspicion what I've learned
about is a few cases where college
presidents I know were out campaigning
for foreign students in foreign
countries and I a couple of my know I'm
friendly with and I said why are you
doing that and the reply was they pay
full tuition and you know tuition is
very high it's not in Hillsdale but most
places it's very high and nobody pays it
but I I suspect I don't know I'm gonna
try to find out that the Chinese
government is is giving in yet was
giving our universities a big cadre of
full tuition payers who are also very
smart they're very smart people and so
there's some you know it's government
money of a different kind and I think we
should I agree with you we should
disrupt that yeah well you know you
don't have to investigate Larry I can
tell you that is the case that for many
colleges especially in their science and
technology fields they actively recruit
Chinese students other foreign nationals
as well that Chinese students in
particular because they pull pay full
freight they don't take a dollar of
scholarship money or need-based
financial aid and in many if not most
cases those students are this sons and
daughters of well-connected Chinese
Communist Party officials people they
know will be loyal to the party that
will take advantage of our most advanced
labs and classrooms and then come back
to China and employ that knowledge on
behalf of the Chinese state I think we
should get our students in India if we
need a lot of foreign students because
they're pretty smart and then or or like
I said you should bring more Chinese
students to the United States to study
things like the Federalist Papers
because China needs democracy more than
they need artificial intelligence
yeah I think that's a good you know the
way it works in Hills no you teach some
at Hillsdale you know nobody comes into
class to represent a point of view we're
supposed to work together to figure out
what the truth of the matter is and that
means if somebody wants to make the
argument for Carl Marsh good luck to
them and it would be a healthy
atmosphere I'm gonna get me some Chinese
students maybe now in defense policy are
you talked about urgent needs are we on
track are we doing what we need to be
doing to keep up to keep ahead of them
we were on track but we need to get
moving faster down the track some of
that's related to the virus itself the
defense industry just like any industry
has been adversely affected by the
pandemic so you're gonna see cost
overruns and budget overruns for a lot
of our defense contractors as a result
of their factories having to shut down
because of the spread of the virus so
the first and most immediate thing we
have to do is make sure that we spend
the money that offsets those overruns so
we don't take it down to future budgets
or just end up getting fewer ships
submarines aircraft or what-have-you but
we also need to accelerate the
acquisition of the kind of systems that
are gonna offset China's advantage in
the western Pacific like I said the kind
of intermediate-range missiles that we
were prohibited from building under an
obsolete treaty with the Soviet Union
until just last year whereas China has
thousands and thousands of missiles on
its coast
targeted Taiwan and our bases in South
Korea and Japan and Guam the kind of
stealth aircraft they're gonna be
critical to offsetting Chinese power and
the kinds of naval ships especially
submarines that are so critical
offsetting Chinese power this has been a
welcome development under the Trump
administration to start reinvesting in
the kinds of weapons that we need terror
a competitor like China as opposed to
continue to fight low-level insurgencies
against terrorists which is still
important but China is the most critical
and dangerous threat we face in the long
run our military is moving in the right
direction we should be moving faster
though oh yeah I'm teaching a course on
Churchill which I often do and this time
I learned something
better than I've ever known it I found a
map and put it up of the British Empire
and then I colored in the parts that
Churchill thought were most important
and almost all of the British Empire was
along the coast of Eurasia and and the
parts that he didn't care about so much
were the parts that were not on the
coast and that's because great maritime
power not a very big country and then if
you look at a map of the world the
United States isn't you know the world's
a lot smaller than it used to be because
of Technology but 85% of the world's
people live in Eurasia Africa and we are
located in between the two coasts of
that great landmass and that means Navy
and air power and allies along the coast
our alliances along the coast of Eurasia
strong so our alliances are strong they
need to be stronger and our focus needs
to be first and foremost on that Asian
littoral especially in the western
Pacific where China is trying to build a
foothold in which it can project power
first in its region then throughout
Eurasia and then all around the world
which said about Churchill is we'll take
in thinking as he was from an island off
the northern coast of Europe you can
apply that to America though as well
we're really just a continental sized
version of Great Britain when you think
about geopolitics and what you laid out
is something that your old teacher bill
Roode would have laid out he would have
said that geography is the most
fundamental aspect of geopolitics
because it's the most eternal it never
changes and it's simply a fact that
China has an advantageous geography to
influence events throughout Asia
especially East in South Asia and that's
something that we have to work to deter
and that's why we are a great maritime
and air power even though so many of our
wars have been fought over so many years
on land whether it in Iraq and
Afghanistan Vietnam World War two order
one so forth
ultimately we had to fight to get in
there to be able to conduct those Wars
on land that means naval power
it means air power that
is also how we deter those words from
happening in the first place which is a
curse of course the most urgent matter
of strategy is to stop Wars from
starting in the first place do you think
the people of America realized the role
of China I mean let's talk about that
one more second because when this thing
started we didn't have good information
and we continued not to get good
information from the place where it
started did that set us back in our
reaction to the to the virus is it
costing as money is it making it worse
there's no doubt that China's lies and
it's disinformation in January really
even back to December Larry have made
this outbreak much more severe than it
had to be in fact there's some studies
that suggest if China had just acted a
week or two earlier it could have
reduced the number of cases worldwide by
two-thirds or even up to 90% that may
seem a lot for just a week or two of
inaction but as we've seen sometimes
just a few days in some of our big
cities or states in the United States
have made a large difference if China
had been open and transparent from the
very beginning if it had asked for help
help from the United States from Japan
from the European Union in December to
identify what was happening Wuhan this
might have just been a local outbreak in
Wuhan not even who by prevents and
certainly not all mainland China but
rather it lied to symbol to covered up
it tried to intimidate others and as a
result we have a global pandemic that is
going to lead to an economic contract
contraction as severe as anything since
the Great Depression
China is directly responsible for those
actions and I can assure you the
American people understand that China
was not very popular with the American
people
before this pandemic now they beaut I
know as a pariah state mmm good less so
in Europe probably China public opinion
about China is trending in a very bad
direction for Beijing all around the
world maybe not as maybe not as severe
as it is in the United States but and
again this is popular opinion not elite
opinion but popular opinion not only the
United States but in Europe even in
Africa which is has some of China's
closest partners
public opinion is moving pretty rapidly
away from China as it should okay how
long do you think it'll take us to get
out of this mess it's hard to say Larry
because there's so many unknown still
about this virus but I have to say that
over the last month our people have done
a very good job of working hard to
arrest the spread of the virus and
that's ultimately what it will take to
get people back to work back into their
normal economic routines to get the
economy back on its feet is to arrest
the spread of the virus to and make
people believe rightly that they're less
likely to contract the virus and
critically that will have a functioning
health care system and hopefully very
soon drugs that will help treat them so
they may get sick but they won't die
from this virus once they have the
confidence to do that we'll begin to get
back to something like normal and then
obviously as the president's Task Force
said a couple weeks ago this is gonna be
a rolling gradual calibrated set of
decisions what works for one region is
not gonna work for another region
obviously in New York City is the
hardest hit region in the entire country
it's going to need its own special
strategy that's gonna be very different
from what you see in Michigan or
Arkansas and in Arkansas what literally
what's right for Little Rock may not be
right for Pocahontas may not be right
for Darnell so this is gonna be a
decision set of decisions that are made
by our governors and local officials as
we begin to get people back into the
work place hopefully back to their
normal routines still with taking
precautions like wearing masks not
shaking hands washing your hands and so
forth but I do think that we're looking
at a matter of weeks not months before
we can begin to get back to something
like normal with prudent precautions in
most of the country so Tom that's great
and I would say that I would
congratulate you on your courage here
more warmly than I do if I thought you
cared much about the opinion of The
Washington Post
but haven't no you don't but it is an
insight that you've had here and then a
stubbornness rising to courage to keep
talking about this when everybody wanted
to talk about something else and they
were calling you a conspiracy theory
and I think you're to be thanked for
that well thank you Larry I appreciate
it and great to talk and I know our
people who are watching this there'll be
many are going to have enjoyed it and
we'll do it again thank you and thanks
for hosting this very important
symposium good take care